tenemos este problema dice karla farah
entrena para una carrera y está
corriendo vueltas alrededor de una
cancha si cada vuelta es de 300 yardas
cuántas vueltas completas tiene que dar
para correr al menos dos millas bueno
queremos que corra dos millas y tenemos
la longitud de cada vuelta en yardas
sería bueno pasar todo a una misma
unidad así que déjame pasar todo a
yardas
vamos a transformar estas dos millas
vale entonces las voy a poner por aquí
abajo dos millas millas y aquí tenemos
que multiplicar por la tasa de
conversión de millas a yardas pero la
verdad no me acuerdo de esa tasa de
conversión afortunadamente si me acuerdo
de la tasa de conversión entre millas y
pies ésta me la aprendí a alguna vez
porque me pareció algo algo útil para
tenerlo ahí en la cabeza una milla y
resulta que una milla es igual a cinco
mil cinco mil doscientos ochenta pies
entonces lo primero que vamos a hacer es
convertir las millas a pies y luego usar
que hay tres pies por yarda para pasar
todo halladas
entonces aquí tenemos que convertir a
pies de modo que en el numerador voy a
poner pies y en el denominador tengo que
poner millas millas o bueno y millas a
esta millas y con esto las millas se
cancelan con millas sólo que ahora aquí
debo de poner números que pues vengan de
la tasa de conversión y justo aquí ya lo
puse verdad una milla cinco mil 280 pies
entonces una milla es cinco mil 280 pies
muy bien vamos a realizar esta operación
a ver qué nos queda las millas se
cancelan con millas
aquí nos quedan dos por cinco mil
doscientos ochenta pues dos por cinco
mil es 10.000 y dos por 280 es 560 así
que nos queda 10 mil quinientos sesenta
y las unidades son pies pies si hice
aquí viene la multiplicación creo que la
hice muy rápido déjame hacerla aquí a la
derecha
para verificarla entonces es 5 1280 x 2
ok entonces 2 por cerveceros 2 por 8 es
16 y llevamos 12 por 12 4 y 15 2 por 5
es 10 si 10.560 entonces 2 millas es 10
mil 560 10 y ahora vamos a utilizar la
tasa de conversión entre yardas y pies
sabemos que en una hallada en una yarda
hay 3 pies 3
entonces déjame pasar aquí abajo voy a
utilizar este color naranja ahora
tenemos diez mil quinientos sesenta pies
pies y queremos pasarlo a yardas
entonces hay que multiplicar en el
numerador por yardas yardas y tenemos
que dividir tenemos que dividir entre
pies poner en el denominador pies
entonces aquí tenemos la tasa de
conversión una yarda es 3 pies
entonces arriba van las yardas una yarda
es 3 pies o bien podemos pensar lo que
un tercio de yarda es un pie y esto
tiene sentido verdad estamos pasando de
pies a yardas las yardas son unidades
más grandes que los pies entonces
debemos tener menos de esta cantidad y
por eso estamos dividiendo entre 3 aquí
arriba también tiene sentido verdad
estamos pasando de millas a pies que son
unidades más chiquitas y por eso tiene
sentido multiplicar por este número pero
bueno vamos a hacer las cuentas acá pies
se cancela con pies las unidades nos
quedan yardas y nos queda nos queda
10.560 entre 3
yardas yardas déjame realizar la
división de casita para ver cuánto nos
queda la voy a poner en color verde
entonces es 10.000 10.560 dividido
dividido entre 33 no caben 13 caben 10 3
veces 3 por 3 99 restamos
queda 1 estamos bajo el 53 cabe 5 veces
en 15 3 por 5 es 15 restamos que da 0
bajáis 63 cabe dos veces en 62 por 13 6
restamos aquí queda 0 baje el 0 queda
cero y aquí hay otro cero verdad
entonces queda 3500 20 yardas lo voy a
poner aquí esto es 3500 20 yardas yardas
vale entonces dos millas son 10 mil 560
pies que son 3 mil 520 yardas pero
todavía no hemos terminado porque ahora
tenemos que ver cuántas vueltas tiene
que dar carla para y cómo le hacemos
pues aquí también tenemos la tasa de
conversión entre yardas y vueltas
entonces vamos a ver estas yardas
cuántas vueltas son entonces hay que
multiplicar por y déjame cambiar de
color voy a poner este color rojo
entonces ahora queremos ver cuántas
vueltas son de modo que en el numerador
tocan vueltas
estás
y en el denominador toca yardas yardas
y la tasa de conversión es que una
vuelta una vuelta son 300 300 yardas
yardas se cancela con yardas y nos queda
que esto es igual a 3 mil 520 dividido
dividido entre 300 vueltas vueltas
ahora podríamos hacer la división de
casita para ver cuántas vueltas son pero
en vez de hacer eso bueno lo puedes
hacer por tu cuenta si tú quieres pero
en vez de hacer eso vamos a aproximar
cuánto es esta cantidad de vueltas por
ejemplo cuántos son once vueltas vamos a
pensar por aquí abajo cuántos son 11
vueltas 11 11 vueltas vueltas
bueno pues 11 vueltas 11 vueltas es lo
mismo es lo mismo que 11 por trescientas
yardas lo voy a abreviar así sale porque
cada vuelta es de 300 yardas y esto es
igual a 3300 tres mil 300 yardas y bueno
esto todavía no es lo mismo que tres mil
quinientos veinte yardas verdad todavía
no lo alcanzamos entonces 11 vueltas no
son suficientes para llegar a las 2
millas y 12 vueltas vamos a ver qué pasa
con 12 vueltas vueltas
12 vueltas es 12 por 300 yardas
300 yardas y aquí nos quedaría 3 por 236
entonces sería 3600 ya estás y con estas
12 vueltas ya llegamos o más bien ya
pasamos las 3500 20 yardas así que para
encontrar el número exacto de vueltas
así con todo y su fracción tendríamos
que hacer la división para ver cuánto
nos queda pero vamos a ver si eso
resuelve la pregunta a ver la pregunta
es cuántas vueltas completas a esto es
importante cuántas vueltas completas
completas tiene que dar para correr al
menos dos millas pues entonces ya
tenemos aquí abajo la respuesta verdad
11 vueltas no son suficientes para
llegar a las 3500 20 yardas porque sólo
son 3 mil 300 yardas entonces 11 vueltas
pues no todavía no es suficiente pero ya
que vimos 12 vueltas justo en ese
momento corremos 3600 yardas y si con
eso ya nos alcanza para pasar las dos
millas vale entonces pues necesitamos 12
vueltas necesitamos 12 vueltas para
correr
bueno al menos tres mil 520 yardas o
bien 10 mil 560 pies o bien dos millas y
con eso terminamos el problema